[Music]
this week 48 hours investigates the
suspicious death of a wisconsin mother
todd kendhammer says his wife barbara
was killed in a freak accident on a road
in 2016
but a jury did not believe him he was
convicted of her murder and sentenced to
life behind bars
now his new lawyers say there is new
evidence that the jury never saw
erin moriarty reports
on the morning of september 16 2016
todd kandhammer told investigators that
a pipe flew off a truck smashed through
the windshield of his car and gravely
injured his wife barbara there was a
pipe in the ground no come out of that
tree off the truck she later died at a
hospital here's the area where the pipe
went through the windshield the story
didn't make sense to la crosse wisconsin
prosecutor tim grinke for one thing
investigators never found the mysterious
truck and todd kendhammer gave police
different accounts of where he was going
that morning it only makes sense one way
is that he caused her injuries caused
her death and tried to cover it up a
jury agreed guilty in december of 2017
todd kandhammer was convicted of
murdering barbara he did not hurt my mom
ever jessica's service is barbara and
todd's daughter he didn't do this and
he deserves to come home
if this could happen to todd kendhammer
it could happen to anybody
jerry buding and kathleen stilling are
todd kendhammer's appeals lawyers they
managed to get him back in court for an
evidentiary hearing good morning judge
morning this summer they presented the
judge with new pieces of evidence here's
the pipe coming off including this pipe
demo test that was conducted by
investigators after the incident
kendhammer's trial lawyers who thought
the pipe test was inconclusive never
shared the video with judge or jury and
neither did the state look how it
bounces
and comes up really high
in your minds those videos show it could
have happened that's the point yes
and now both sides await a judge's
decision on a new trial do you have any
concerns at all that you might have
convicted an innocent man not in this
case no
[Music]
and aaron joins us now aaron the the
pipe uh
method of death if that's what it is is
very freaking d if it's an accident uh
when will we know if todd will get a new
trial well the judge is going to and has
been deciding since last summer whether
this new evidence would have made a
difference at his trial the jury might
have reached a different verdict and if
the judge thinks that then he may offer
a new trial but let me tell you this is
truly a mystery yeah when i come here
and i say
i'm not sure then you've got to take my
word for that because um
the state says that this man killed his
wife snapped they have he has no history
of violence with her so
what's the motivation
that's one of the trouble there doesn't
appear to be a motive the insurance
policy there was more money on his life
than on hers
they can't find the weapon they can't
identify what weapon he used to kill her
i mean she had serious injuries there
had to be a weapon if he caused those
injuries and they're saying he staged
this in a matter of
five minutes five minutes so he would
have like he would have snapped that's
what the state says and then went oh
there's a pipe in the back of the car i
think i'll break the windshield twice
then
yeah it's so wow but
but he took the stand and he changed his
story three times it's it's a mystery
the jury didn't believe it it is a
mystery his family supports it much of
his family supports him including his
kids it's going to be very interesting
and her mother and her mother wow
you can see aaron's report mystery and
it clearly is a mystery mystery on
county road m tomorrow night at 10 9
central right here on cbs and on the
viacom cbs streaming service paramount
plus
we'll be right back